Speaker 1: Hey, this is super interesting me. I
David Pakman. I am featured in a 2022 campaign
ad. This is super interesting. Now, to be clear,
I have not endorsed this candidate. They've just
used video of me talking about stuff. It doesn't
even have anything to do with Charles Graham,
but it's very interesting. Charles Graham is
running in North Carolina and is going at David
Rouser David Rouser, who is also running in North
Carolina and has previously said how much he likes
Jesse Helms, the racist, far right senator
who was against civil rights and against gay
rights and against just about any kind of rights.
Check out the very beginning of this campaign ad.
It's very cool to see myself in it. Take a look.
Speaker 3: Everything I know in life came from
my years with Helms, I had a great education.
Speaker 4: Jesse Helms used to be a senator who
opposed the Civil Rights Act, oppose the Voting
Rights Act, called the Civil Rights Act dangerous.
Speaker 3: I don't think I ever learned any
more than I did when I was with Senator Helms.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Charles Graham is
currently a member of the North Carolina
House of Representatives for the 47th District.
And he's a member of the I hope I'm pronouncing
this correctly the Lumbee tribe. And Graham is the
only Native American serving in the North Carolina
General Assembly right now. And he is running
for North Carolina's 9th Congressional District.
This is member of the House of Representatives
running against incumbent Republican Dan Bishop.
And it is a very interesting race, and I want
to talk a little more broadly about our plans
for coverage of the midterms and how people can
get involved. I'm getting more and more live
call questions and emails and tweets and comments
from folks saying I want to get involved in 2022.
What are all the best races? I want to be involved
in a ton of races. All 435 members of the House
are up for reelection. A third of the members
of the Senate are up for reelection. There's
a bunch of gubernatorial elections. I think it's
really important to set expectations and recognize
you can't be involved in every race. You can't
phone bank for every race. You can't go out and
knock doors for every race, particularly because,
you know, people generally live in one place and
you're not going to go all over the country. So
I understand the instinct to say I want to do
everything I can to try to prevent Republicans
from taking the House and or the Senate or the
governor's mansions in the state that I live. I
want to do all of it, and I get that. But I think
the risk as we spread ourselves too thin. And so
my recommendation would be for everybody in our
audience to pick one or two races that are either
local to you or that you find to be particularly
important if you live in Florida or Arizona,
but you find Mehmet Oz to be a particularly
weaponized, dangerous candidate in Pennsylvania.
Well, get to work there. Whether it's helping John
Fetterman, who we're going to try to get on the
show or whoever else is pick that. If your local
district is a Purple District and there's
currently a Republican and maybe a Democrat could
win, or maybe there's a Democrat, but they're
at risk of losing the seat to a Republican focus
there. There's so many interesting races it's
impossible to keep up with all of them or even to
be aware of all of the different ways
that you could volunteer your time.
Narrow it down. And that would be the
approach. Now many of you have written to me
saying, David, you should really interview this
primary candidate or that primary candidate.
We can't if if we open up the door to
that, we risk every day every show being
interviews with primary candidates. And although
some of you might like it, most people expect to
get a rundown daily of what's going on, different
stories, et cetera. So we really can't do that.
And so we're going to try to pick and choose
some interesting races. My colleague John
put out a call recently on social media saying,
Who should we talk to? Many of you want me to
talk to both John Fetterman and Mehmet Oz. We're
going to try to make that happen. Many of you have
talked about House races, Senate races. We're
going to try to pick a sort of representative
sample of things and bring it to you. Both
progressives, some incumbent centrist Democrats,
Republicans. We had wacky Republican candidate
Darlene swapper on earlier this week. So we're
going to try to do a little bit of evidence,
everything to the extent that we can, but we
can't cover every race. You can't possibly pay
attention to every race. One last thing. I know
that historically Democrats should get crushed
in November. There's no question about it. We
spoke to Rachel Beter Coffer about it and
we've talked about it six ways to Sunday.
But at the same time, things are really weird.
Everything's been weird since Trump was president,
and if you consider that more Republicans
than Democrats have died of COVID and that
a lot of the Trump people that got involved in
politics for the first time to vote for Trump,
they may not vote in the fall. And I know
it's so cliche because we always say this,
but midterms really come down to turnout. And if
some Republicans don't turn out because they're
dead and some Republicans don't turn out because
Trump's not running for anything, it doesn't have
to be a disaster for Democrats. I'm not making
a prediction. But it doesn't have to be. And
there's really a big opportunity to do some hard
work and and maybe retain control of one or both
House and or Senate. So that's my thought right
now. We have more interviews upcoming for you.